I'm gonna talk to you tonight about
coming out of the closet and not in the
traditional sense not just the gay
closet I think we all have closets your
closet may be telling someone you love
her for the first time we're telling
someone that you're pregnant we're
telling someone you have cancer
or any of the other hard conversations
we have throughout our lives all the
closet is is a hard conversation and
although our topics may vary
tremendously the experience of being in
and coming out of the closet is
universal it is scary and we hate it and
it needs to be done several years ago I
was working at the Southside walnut cafe
a local diner in town and during my time
there I would go through phases of
militant lesbian intensity not shaving
my armpits quoting Ani DiFranco lyrics
as gospel and depending on the bagginess
of my cargo shorts and how recently I
had shaved my head the question would
often be sprung on me usually by a
little kid um are you boy or are you a
girl and there would be an awkward
silence at the table i clenched my jaw a
little tighter hold my coffee pot with a
little more vengeance the dad would
awkwardly shuffle his newspaper and the
mom would shoot a chilling star at her
kid but I would say nothing and I would
see the inside and he got the point that
every time I walked up to a table that
had a kid anywhere between 3 and 10
years old I was ready to fight
and that is a terrible feeling so I
promised myself the next time I would
say something I would have that hard
conversation so within a matter of weeks
it happens again are you boy or you a
girl familiar silence but this time I'm
ready and I am about to go all Women's
Studies 101 on this table I've got my
Betty Ford in quotes I've got my Gloria
Steinem quotes I even got this little
bit from Vagina Monologues I'm gonna do
so I take a deep breath and I look down
and staring back at me is a
four-year-old girl in a pink dress not a
challenge to a feminist duel just a kid
with a question are you a boy are you a
girl so take another deep breath squat
down next to her and say hey I know it's
kind of confusing my hair is short like
a boys and I wear boys clothes but I'm a
girl and you know how sometimes you like
to wear a pink dress and sometimes you
like to wear your comfy jammies well I'm
more of a comfy jammies kind of girl and
this kid looks me dead in the eye
without missing a beat and says my
favorite pajamas are purple with fish
can I get a pancake please and that was
it just though okay you're a girl how
about that pancake it was the easiest
hard conversation I have ever had and
why because Pinkett girl and I we were
both real with each other so like many
of us I've lived in a few closets in my
life and yeah most often my walls
happened to be rainbow but inside in the
dark you can't tell what color the walls
are you just know what it feels like to
live in a closet so really my closet is
no different than yours or yours or
yours sure I'll give you a hundred
reasons why coming out of my closet was
harder than coming out of yours but
here's the thing heart is not relative
heart is hardened who can tell me that
explaining to someone you just declared
bankruptcy is harder than telling
someone you just cheated on them who can
tell me that his coming out story is
harder than telling your five-year-old
you're getting a divorce there is no
harder there is just
hard we need to stop ranking our heart
against everyone else is hard to make us
feel better or worse about our closets
and just commiserate on the fact that we
all have hard at some point in our lives
we all live in closets and they may feel
safe or at least safer than what lies on
the other side of that door but I am
here to tell you no matter what your
walls are made of a closet is no place
for a person to live Thanks
so imagine yourself 20 years ago me I
had a ponytail a strapless dress and
high-heeled shoes I was not the militant
lesbian ready to fight any foretold that
walked into the cafe I was frozen by
fear
curled up in the corner of my
pitch-black closet clutching my gay
grenade and moving one muscle is the
scariest thing I have ever done my
family my friends complete strangers I
had spent my entire life trying to not
disappoint these people and now I was
turning the world upside down
I'm purpose I was burning the pages of
the script we had all followed for so
long but if you do not throw that
grenade it will kill you one of my most
memorable grenade tosses was at my
sister's wedding
it was the first time that many in
attendance knew I was gay so in doing my
maid of honor duties in my black dress
and heels I walked around to tables and
finally landed on table of my parents
friends folks that had known me for
years and after a little small talk one
of the women shouted out
I love Nathan Lane and the Battle of gay
related bility had begun Ashe of Europe
into the Castro well yeah actually we
have friends in San Francisco we've
never been there but we heard it's
fabulous
asked you no my hairdresser Antonio he's
really good and he has never talked
about a girlfriend Ashe what's your
favorite TV show our favorite TV show
favored Will and Grace and you know who
we love
Jack Jack is our favorite and then one
woman stumped but wanting so desperately
to show her to support to let me know
she was on my side she finally blurted
out well sometimes my husband wears pink
shirts and I had a choice in that moment
as all grenade throwers do I could go
back to my girlfriend and my gay loving
table and mock their responses chastise
their unworldliness and their inability
to jump through the politically correct
gay hoops I had brought with me or I
could empathize with them and realize
that that was maybe one of the hardest
things that they had ever done that's
starting and having that conversation
was them coming out of their closets
sure it would have been easy to point
out where they fell short it's a lot
harder to meet them where they are and
acknowledge the fact that they were
trying and what else can you ask someone
to do but try if you're gonna be real
with someone you've got to be ready for
real in return so hard conversations are
still not my strong suit
ask anybody I have ever dated but I'm
getting better and I follow what I like
to call the three pancake girl
principles now please view this through
gay colored lenses but know what it
takes to come out of any closet is
essentially the same number one be
authentic take the armor off be yourself
that kid in the cafe had no armor but I
was ready for battle if you want someone
to be
with you they need to know that you
bleed to number to be direct just say it
rip the band-aid off if you know you are
gay just say it if you tell your parents
you might be gay they will hold out hope
that this will change do not give them
that sense of false hope and number
three and most important be unapologetic
you are speaking your truth never
apologize for that and some folks might
have gotten hurt along the way so sure
apologize for what you've done but never
apologize for who you are and yeah some
folks may be disappointed but that is on
them not on you those are their
expectations of who you are not yours
that is their story not yours
the only story that matters is the one
that you want to write so the next time
you find yourself in a pitch-black
closet clutching your grenade no we have
all been there before and you may feel
so very alone but you are not and we
know it's hard but we need you out here
no matter what your walls are made of
because I guarantee you there are others
peering through the keyhole of their
closets looking for the next brave soul
to bust the door open so be that person
and show the world that we are bigger
than our closets and that a closet is no
place for a person to truly live
thank you both enjoy your night
[Applause]
you